welcome back to special relativity 820.
after discussing energy and momentum um
and examples with collisions we now want
to talk about forces
and
we get back to the example of alice
traveling to the center of the galaxy
and asking what does it mean in terms of
acceleration
so
we start from newton's second law we
know that a force is a change in
momentum
we can write this down as
d
d dt uh m naught
over
times u over square root 1 minus u
square over c square
or just with a gamma vector
and the thing to consider here is that
now the gamma factor
and the velocity are actually time
dependent so there's two components to
this we'll come back to this
the kinetic energy
is the work done by an external force
and you can get to the kinetic energy by
just integrating let's say from a
particle which is accelerated by an
external force from a velocity zero to
some velocity v
that's the integral um over this over
the path of the particle
of the path of this object times the
force
if you just
assume here uniform
motion in x direction then this
simplifies to just an f dx
okay so as a first activity i want you
to find the kinetic energy of an object
with velocity v
and the mass and mass m naught
and as a second part i want you to test
this result
for velocities much much smaller than
the speed of light where you used to
doing this kind of calculation and
you're familiar with the outcome
so we just have to integrate just have
to integrate so this is a little bit
involved here
so we have to integrate from zero to v m
naught that's our constant you can take
that out d dt of this u um
u times gamma dx okay so you find those
two components here
um
and then we do a trick where you know we
introduce this du the x
the x
um and then the integral becomes an m
times udu
over one minus u square over c square
third
to the third
to this
third power half
okay and then you can just look up the
integral or work it out not that
difficult actually but you find that
this is equal to m naught times c square
over
square root 1 minus u square over c
square which you have to evaluate for
velocities v and 0.
and when you do that you find those two
components here okay the first one is m
naught c square
times gamma and the second one is m
naught c square
so that result is actually not too
surprising as we saw
that we can write the energy
equal to
m naught c square
plus k
and what we just calculated here from
this example
is k
is equal to energy
minus
m naught c square
okay so that result already makes sense
in with respect to the discussion we had
at this point
okay or you can simplify this by saying
the kinetic energy is gamma minus 1
times m naught c square
okay so if we now evaluate this for
small values of of v
as we did before we find that the
kinetic energy is one half m naught v
square and
i find it interesting illustrated what
this means now so if you plot the
kinetic energy of a particle as a
function of its velocity we find that
you know at for small values
those two curves you know basically
overlap because more values
m naught c squared
times gamma minus one is basically the
same
as one half mv square which is
just derived here from the taylor
expansion
but for larger values this diverges and
especially when you get closer to the
speed of light
um you know just to get a quantitative
example i ask you to do another
calculation here i want you to
reinvestigate alice's journey to the
center of the galaxy where she has a
spacecraft which moves with a gamma
factor of 15 000
an acceleration of 10 meters per second
square and the mass of the spacecraft
that says 10 000 metric tons or 10 000
but
sorry 100 metric tons or 100 000
kilograms so compare the kinetic energy
using newtonian mechanics or special
military and you find that the
difference
is astonishingly large so if you just
work this out one half m
c square we can just use c square here
because the velocity is basically
c
um
5 times 10 to the
22 kilograms meter square over second
second square
and in the relativistic terms
the answer is 30 000 times larger
so 30 000 times larger than the
classical k so the huge difference
between the classical evaluation and the
evaluation and the special relativity
one more uh word on m
f equal m a
uh the question is how does this
transform on a learner's transformation
is something we already halfway figured
out so here you basically want to see
how a
uh transforms under loans transformation
we have started the discussion by saying
you know in galilean transformations
acceleration is invariant
while endurance transformation that's
not the case but if you investigate
again the second law of uh of physics
and the force is a change in momentum
you find that you get those two
components here
one
is
[Music]
parallel to the acceleration so m times
gamma a
but the second one is not the second one
is m naught times u
times the change in time of the gamma
factor and that's not parallel
to f or to a
and so you find that
there's two the new vector the new force
of a particle is not parallel to the
acceleration anymore that's kind of
content to
content